your phone is cracked you phone me
you need a new ipad you phone me you
need a new phone you phone me laptop
ipads whatever you want brothers and
sisters
your phone us not me because i don't do
phone repairs but if you come to phone
ask brothers and sisters
you can get this guy if you mention my
name and they are sponsors for this
amazing video
check it out inshallah don't go anywhere
no no so how can something start off so
small
and yet be so vast now no because who
made the first cell
you're just coming up with like dumb
questions yeah exactly thumb in it
prove to me god exists you got it um
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends
we are here in central london today with
an experiment we're going to stop
uh atheists and the challenge is that
they're going to put theirself in the
theater's shoe for a
couple of minutes and give the best
example for god's existence if they win
which we're going to choose we're going
to interview a couple of people whoever
has the best argument we're going to get
their contact details and we're going to
find them and give them
their airports inshallah you should put
yourself in a fierce position
and i want you to give me the best
evidence for god well firstly because um
okay what what was there before the
universe you know what caused it to what
caused the big bang there must have been
their cause
so no it came by a chance huh no but the
probability like
scientifically like what a bunch of
molecule energy just came out of nowhere
like there must have been a reason for
it to
start in the first place okay what if i
said energy's always been there
well well we know that the universe
existed for 14 billion years
but there's there's a court there must
have been a cause and what's wrong with
believing that the cause must have been
god you know
okay prove to me god exists what's that
what's the best argument you can
convince me with
where did we come from um
okay i'm gonna pretend
where did evolution start um
from the first cell there is no no
because
who made the first cell
no offense you've gone away how are we
over here like
are we monkeys or i don't reckon we are
monkeys because
even though they say we're monkeys i'm
don't like monkey he don't look like a
monkey he don't like
it does he no so that's another so what
if i said
about evolution argument if i said that
it's not evolution man
prove to me god exists what's your best
argument for god's existence
i mean how we hear like how's a simple
like the big bang
how did it cause all of this to happen
came from nothing well how would that
come from nothing there has to be
something that made it
wait wait what are we talking about are
we talking about god being real god not
being no no prove to me that god
exists oh i get it yeah but
how yeah as i said how they come from
nothing like all of this
something has to have like medals why
can you know can it not
come from nothing of course not like why
not from nothing
it doesn't make sense does it i don't
know tell me why it doesn't
because it doesn't like us none
otherwise what argument would you use to
prove to me that god exists
so with the big bang theory um nothing
can just
spontaneously combust it has to be
something that must have
been omnipotent being on the banana
being that must have brought us all into
this world that has
created us from in his image in so can
can can he not come from nothing we're
made so
intricately and individually we're all
so special that it can't be
it can't be random or that it was made
it was designed it was by design there
was
nebulous gases and whatever and after a
certain amount of time
two chemicals came together we had the
big bang and then that's where we come
from
okay so so i believe all of that came
from nothing the gases
yeah if i said i believe all of that
came from nothing the gases and
everything the atoms and the energy
i believe it was nothing and nothing
just
exploded what would you say to me
where that come from
i'm sorry can it not come by chance
maybe i don't think it can come by
chance like something has to have made
it it doesn't make sense for all of this
from like simple why does something have
to make it if i said that
come on um
joseph let's let's start with yourself
well the universe
is billions of billions maybe even
infinite
of light years long so how can something
start off so small
and yet be so fast now okay what if i
responded with big bang
well how can the big bang be so
small when like they say it was once the
size of an orange so i'm going to be
that small
and now this big well if there was no
god then why would there be any type of
nice in the world
at all people wouldn't want to be nice
if there was just the devil right
everyone would want to be
awful and horrible so if there's a god
and that's a good sign the devil's the
bad side
the god brings out the nicest people
like when i say it's when i'm up here i
say nice once the girls to make them
feel like
good like themselves because i want to
do something nice with people so you're
saying the presence of goodness
proves that there is god when you know
good you should know god
okay but what if somebody responds and
says what about the presence of evil
doesn't that negate god there's also the
devil there's good and bad in everything
that ever happened i'll prove to me god
exists
um having the belief in something higher
than ourselves that there is a set path
for us
gives us the opportunity to kind of
figure out where we're moving in life
and how to how to
how to um conduct ourselves in like a in
a mannerism
that is most respectful to everyday
human beings no matter where their
backgrounds are from
but also with the chance you're sure
you're not a theist and evidence for god
i just think humans are such complex
beings compared to the rest of the world
we have a conscience
morals everything it's just so much more
than just
science i think i can't i don't think it
can be an evolutionary
explanation for something so kind of
moral and beautiful this human life
i just think i just think it has to be
something created by something divine
my teammates are not really helping no
no no go
go go go he knows he's laughing at my
argument he's so dead and he's right
yeah i know you're just coming up with
like dumb questions
exactly dominic that's my point an
atheist would say
i believe everything came from chance
right so you believe in evolution
but at the same time you do fear death
everyone fears death in
one way or another but if you don't
believe in a higher power you believe
that
once you die you pretty much don't exist
but some people believe that you are
conscious and you're
just finished so you're saying just the
mere fact that you're conscious
means that there's a god exactly that
can nothing
just explode and there has to be
something there for it to explode in the
first place
can it not be chance i mean you can't
really
say it's from charles if it's nothing
there in the first place
so something can't happen by chance if
there's nothing there
okay so you so you believe it has to be
a cause it has to be of course
like okay
you got me that was good what may have
worked with the big fans
he may have created the big band for
everything to happen here do you think
that you'll be here right now i have a
little
explosion think about how can an
explosion make an animal come out of
nowhere
okay all right everything particles
everything love is just going to come
out of mass exposure there's always
something up there that's going to make
something happen
out of nowhere completely isn't it are
you sure you're not fierce
can i not say it came from nothing
you could but surely it's more likely
that
something caused it right yeah
i don't know but i believe the universe
came from nothing
nothing it was nothing and then the
universe popped into existence
how would you refute that
i came from nothing
so nothing can create something
yeah nothing can create something yeah
don't even work in maths why you get
zero
zero times seven what's that
i need to go major if it was all by
chance then we'd just go on
living meaningless lives why do humans
actually seek self-actualization
and a greater purpose to see their
purpose why are we here i don't think
that would occur if we just happen by
accident
yeah now can something come from nothing
no of course not
like a human like a human when you have
a child and you birth a child and you
bring it chilled up
you decide how that child will be in the
future the scissors that you make
make that child so they like it's like
all right
so you're as a mother you're the cause
of the baby therefore as human beings we
need the cause which is a creator
yeah so you're telling me it can't come
from nothing
a human comes from nothing no it doesn't
it comes from a family and the mother
who's birthed it
because uh an atheist argument is that
everything comes from nothing it comes
by chance
there was like a primary primary nebuli
and then it exploded
and then we're here today no i don't
think it does i think
i do i don't believe in exactly like
heaven and hell and god but i do believe
there's something out there because
there's things that like supernatural
stuff but how would you explain that
how would you explain that there was a
chance that your life consciousness came
from chance
um and that's not proof but people
specifically want proof of
oh they were written how were they
written who did it who did that
and who did this and who did i'm
spinning bars here and you sure you're
not a theist
i'm a bit drunk but okay okay okay so
drunk on knowledge if i said i believe
we came from nothing
how would you disprove me if i said i
believe this whole universe and
everything came from nothing well
how so if we came from nothing what what
started nothing
i don't know it was just nothing and it
just just died itself
yeah but what what started that what is
nothing if
something started nothing what is that
there's got to be something that started
nothing
yeah that's true okay all right so do
you not understand that
that's your my position is actually your
position so do you not
think that it's a bit silly to believe
that this whole universe came from
nothing
i don't think so like it just can't come
from nothing yeah that's what i'm saying
though that's what i'm saying now let's
go to original positions you're an
atheist
i'm a theist yes forget the plan
you believe that yes
how do you believe that he was laughing
at him a minute ago do you not believe
that we have a course
no so he came from nothing yeah okay
what's your evidence
what's your evidence for god being real
huh simple so for example for what give
me simple
simple can zero
yeah it can how um if you do like
one take away zero then
we're taking away one zero no no can
zero equal one
yeah i don't know what this is all about
now i get it you get it so how could
how could something come from nothing
quantum mechanics what quantum mechanics
gonna do with it
oh because he's just using big words for
the sake of it because humans are a bad
thing
and there is a law called murphy's law
right murphy eddie murphy
where did we come from there's a law
called murphy's law which says anything
bad that can happen
will happen and because humans are bad
they're causing climate change which is
killing our police where do we come from
our polar bears
where did we come from that's the point
we're atheists we believe so i'm
challenging your position now yes i know
and we said that nothing can't exist
exactly
so are you convinced of your own
argument yeah i mean
there's no there's no argument i get
where you're coming from
where's the tree come from the seed
right where does it come from
this is where where's how's the seed
made maybe from nothing maybe nothing
nothing just it can't everything pretty
much is a seed
for millions of years of evolution and
chance
and just elements coming together how is
that going to come out of nowhere think
about it realistically there's always
got to be something to make something
right
so how do you make pasta we might pass
it don't we yeah so they've got the
world here how is the world going to be
made by nothing someone's obviously made
the world out of nothing
so you're telling me that god made
everything yeah yes
and who had made god
[Music]
he's been there there's always obviously
always been something there correct
necessary
it's god is necessary okay okay that's a
very good argument you know it's
had me convinced as well